[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro du 7 8
au sommet on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé vendredi
l'expérimentation avec le ministère de
l'intérieur d'un ballon captif chargé de
surveiller le futur site olympique du
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on en parlera
dans un instant avec nos invités
Anne-Caroline Lemire bonjour vous êtes
responsable des grands comptes de safran
ils expliqueraient ce qu'est cette cette
grande entreprise que ça prend et
Jean-Michel fourgouse bonjour vous êtes
merdéencourt et le président de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et vous êtes
évidemment très intéressé par tout ce
qui touche la sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques et puis Nicolas nandrie vont
nous présenter évidemment ce projet on
va parler aussi de aussi d'innovation
avec l'École des Mines qui s'installe à
Versailles il a très prestigieuse école
des mines qui a été créée vous savez par
Louis XVI en
1783 pour former à l'origine des jetons
des directeurs intelligents pour les
mines du royaume de France
ça a changé depuis et l'École des Mines
ouvre un campus de l'innovation à
Versailles on fera le point avec Gabriel
Gonthier et puis belle moisson de
médailles où je pars à cyclisme au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin de on en
parlera évidemment avec notre consultant
Yann dujari champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste et puis Michael et le
midoro qui ouvrira évidemment comme tous
les lundis une grande page sport mais
tout de suite la météo la méthode
lendemain qu'est-ce qui vous attend
demain vous savez ça regardez la carte
ça va être terrible le matin c'est pas
si mal le matin c'est pas si mal mais
c'est un peu encore nuageux et puis peu
à peu les températures vont s'élever le
soleil va briller demain après-midi sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines voilà pour la
météo et on va parler des cinq infos du
jour avec vous Mathilde et on va
commencer justement par une information
sur le temps qu'il fait et bien oui
Patrice parce que ce weekend il a flotté
un air d'été dans les Yvelines avec des
températures très douces pour un mois
d'octobre la France vit en ce moment un
épisode de chaleur remarquable et les
Yvelines ni échappent les températures
sont en moyenne à 20 degrés la journée
avec des ressentis pouvant aller jusqu'à
25 et cela inquiète certains Yvelines
beaucoup de problèmes pour la suite pour
l'écologie c'est très alarmant donc
c'est très agréable de se balader en
pull sans manteau mais c'est
complètement déréglé donc c'est très
mauvais pour la pour la suite ma méthode
d'esprit effectivement beaucoup
d'inquiétudes pour l'avenir
on profite de pouvoir faire des balades
au bord de Seine tranquillement mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas du tout normal
et la chaleur fait pas plaisir à tout le
monde fait pas plaisir à tout le monde
et le moi d'octobre 2022 sera sans doute
le mois d'octobre le plus chaud et
jamais enregistré on compte à peu près
3,5 moyenne en plus pour ce mois-ci
3,5 à 3,8 c'est le chiffre du jour
exactement Patrice c'est le nombre de
personnes travaillant à temps plein au
sein du service de pédiatrie de
l'hôpital de Poissy
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en temps normal
ils doivent être 15 médecins et donc à
cause du manque de personnel depuis
vendredi dernier les parents qui se
présentent avec leur enfant ne sont plus
accueillis le service ne prend que les
hospitalisations et les enfants adressés
par le SAMU la situation devrait durer
jusqu'au 7 novembre on va faire le point
sur la pénurie d'essence est-ce que ça
s'améliore notamment dans les Yvelines
et bien la situation s'améliore
parce
que en Île-de-France une station sur 4
manques au moins d'un carburant
cependant le rationnement à la pompe
élevée fini la restriction des 30 litres
maximum par automobiliste et si vous
avez la chance de partir en vacances
sachez que 90% des stations sont bien
approvisionnées sur le réseau
autoroutier alors ça n'empêche pas cette
pénurie d'essence la fête foraine de
Versailles qui ouvre ses portes tout à
fait les manèges sont de retour sur le
parking de l'Europe à Versailles
jusqu'au 13 novembre pêche aux canards
auto-tamponneuses palais du rire bateau
pirate il y en a pour tous les goûts la
fête sera ouverte tous les jours de 14h
à 20h et on termine par l'image du jour
qui est plutôt l'image de demain parce
que il y aurait une des clipse partielle
de du soleil il sera possible demain
d'observer cette éclipse partielle
solaire en France à partir de 11h15
c'est très précis durant deux heures
environ la lune viendra cacher un petit
morceau du soleil mais sans nous plonger
dans l'obscurité par contre Patrice en
2026 en août j'ai fait mes petites
recherches il y aura une éclipse totale
donc là on sera vraiment plongé dans
l'obscurité merci beaucoup Mathilde
Franco pour ces informations et on
commence donc avec ce ballon ce ballon
stationnaire comme on dit exactement
captif bon on captif qui qui survole qui
a survolé vendredi le vélo de route de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il a peut-être
surpris certains 5 continents et 50
ninois ce ballon parce que donc il était
au dessus de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à proximité du
vélo drone national c'était vendredi
dernier donc il s'agissait en fait d'une
expérimentation technologique de
surveillance du futur site olympique qui
va accueillir les épreuves de cyclisme
sur piste en 2024 un ballon captif à 120
mètres d'altitude qui embarque plusieurs
outils technologiques de surveillance ce
dispositif est actuellement testé et
pourrait être utilisé durant les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris en
2024 on écoute à ce propos le préfet
Olivier de Mazières délégué au
partenariat aux stratégies et aux
innovations de sécurité on a 170
expérimentations de ce type qu'on est en
train de conduire pour un compte du
ministère de l'Intérieur en relation
étroite avec les industriels notamment
le comité stratégique de filière des
industries de la sécurité une fois que
ces produits auront été expérimentés
comme aujourd'hui qu'on aura décidé
qu'ils sont efficaces et qu'on les aura
acquis ils seront évidemment à la
disposition et sous l'utilisation pleine
et entière des forces de sécurité dont
c'est le métier ce qui suppose
d'ailleurs c'est important ce que votre
question est importante parce que ça
suppose qu'on tranche assez vite
puisqu'il y a un délai incompressible
d'abord de fournitures dématérielles
ensuite de formation des agents on a
alors Monsieur fourousse quand on voit
cette expérimentation vous aviez
participé à cette expérimentation
vendredi matin qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de ce système de surveillance
écoutez nous on monte en puissance on
sait que c'est la première attente des
Français sécurité avec le pouvoir
d'achat bon on a augmenté la police
municipale d'abord ensuite le magret de
canine ensuite la Maga des caisses
ensuite la vidéo près de 120 caméras
après les premiers drones à tester après
les drones anti-rhône qui sont aussi
expérimentés avec cette équipe que vous
avez interviewé la 5G bien sûr
maintenant un zeppelin carrément alors
bien sûr c'est l'accélération grâce au
JO et un zeppelin effectivement qui est
électronique qui est qui est dehors très
juste très beau très sympathique et mes
enfants
technologique et donc voilà on continue
notre profession le commissaire du futur
qui a été attribué à Saint-Quentin qui
coordonnera trois commissariats et qui
doit bénéficier bien sûr qu'il doit être
hyper moderne qui va bénéficier bien sûr
de moyens de gérer de
comment dit-on de connexion enfin ce
serait un commissaire hyper connecté les
policiers sont connectés leurs voitures
les trois commissariats ensemble et puis
bien sûr ils ont avec le préfet et bien
sûr les services départementaux de la
sécurité publique donc donc voilà c'est
c'est un c'est un très beau projet ça
correspond aux attentes des Français je
dirais que et aussi à la à l'image
technologique de Saint-Quentin Paris
Seclin je vous rappelle qu'on est dans
les 8 territoires de cuisine au monde et
qui est très forte culture numérique et
bien entendu tous ces projets vous
l'avez compris sont vraiment la
traduction de de l'intelligence
technologique française qui est élevé
surtout dans dans ce territoire
le nombre d'entreprises c'était une
famille bien sûr de safran mais on
bénéficie d'entreprises très haute
valeur ajoutée bien entendu et on est
très heureux de les avoir avant
avec Madame Lemire est-ce que les enjeux
justement de la sécurité dans la
perspective des Jeux olympiques sont
font partie des enjeux les plus
importants et peut-être les plus
délicats à mener ah oui
il est clair que l'ensemble des services
on le voit puisque on est attaqué comme
au processus décisionnel même de
sécurité bien entendu est-ce qu'il y
aura la police nationale bien sûr la
gendarmerie
l'ensemble des militaires puisque en cas
d'intensification à ce moment-là vous
passez la main aux militaire c'est pas
comme ça bon il y aura des privés aussi
des polices privées qui seront enfin des
des sociétés de sécurité privées qui
sont engagés donc il y a quand même un
vaste système de sécurité maximale et de
qualité voilà c'est pas pour ça que on a
des problèmes mais les précautions sont
très fortes alors il y a aussi la
cybersécurité je vous rappelle qu'il y a
eu que j'ai fait aujourd'hui la semaine
dernière
qui est une école de formation
formidable très très haut niveau on a je
vous rappelle qu'on a l'université Paris
s'éclaire est une assez scientifique
numéro un mondial à donc à Shanghai
notamment sur les mathématiques et je
vous rappelle que les mathématiques bien
sûr sont à l'origine quand même de la
révolution numérique donc voilà on est
dans un on est dans un monde
d'accélération et en fait on s'applique
à la sécurité bien sûr donc on est sur
c'est très compatible avec ce gros
projet des JO qui arrivent qui est très
lourd alors la Bonne Nouvelle sinon au
niveau des JO masser qu'on a eu
effectivement les championnats du monde
il y a une semaine où on a eu 7
médailles
cette médaille 3 d'or 3 Argent Une
bronze et puis derrière on a eu une
autre manifestation donc pour sur le
handicap et donc au Vélodrome et là on a
eu 17 médailles ce qui fait 17 + 7 24
donc Michel amis ça en dit long sur
l'image de la France sur sur les plans
sur le vélo sur le vélo
pas mal de médailles aussi mais il y
avait et j'ajoute dans ma carte de
sécurité on en avait parlé aussi qui est
une entreprise de Saint-Quentin qui qui
travaille sur les portiques de sécurité
la start-up lap corps effectivement
collabore avec une PME qui s'appelle
atermès qui est situé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et l'accord
développe des concepts de sûreté c'est à
dire que pour contrôler les personnes
sur des grands événements et ben les
gens ont juste à passer et ça identifie
les potentiels dangers et justement on
va continuer avec la partie industrielle
par rapport à ce ballon captif parce que
il y a l'entreprise c'est Nimr space qui
a développé le ballon mais ensuite il y
a des d'autres entreprises qui
collaborent à ce à ce système notamment
sur les technologies et notamment
l'entreprise ou le groupe s'affront
électronique scènefense le motoriste
aéronautique a développé notamment ce
système euroflear 410 un équipement
obtronique avec plusieurs dispositifs de
détection longue portée donc vous le
voyez vous l'avez vu peut-être à l'image
il est fixé sous le ballon captif et
permet d'assurer une observation assez
large et pour en parler nous sommes avec
Anne Caroline lemide donc il est
responsable grand compte chez ça prend
électronique scène difference et du coup
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste ce système tout à fait
donc eurofir c'est un système de haute
technologie française comprenant
plusieurs caméras permettant de voir
deux jours comme de nuit et dans toutes
les conditions météorologiques grâce
notamment à l'infrarouge et la beauté du
système et qu'il est extrêmement bien
stabilisé en fait tous les des porteurs
aéroportés que ce soit des aérostats
donc des ballons comme des avions ou des
hélicoptères sont soumis à des
vibrations et à des mouvements d'air et
donc pour conserver une image qui soit
nette et qui soit de haute définition
les systèmes comme le refaire 410
doivent bénéficier d'un très haut niveau
de stabilisation ce qui fait partie des
savoir-faire de safran donc ce système
de surveillance finalement est à la
hauteur de l'événement du gros événement
les Jeux Olympiques et les Jeux
paralympiques de 2024 tout à fait c'est
un honneur pour s'affront de contribuer
à la sécurisation des sites qui
accueilleront les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024
puisqu'il est stable vous dites cette
stabilisation là comment on obtient
c'est au sein du système à l'intérieur
du système eurofir 410 d'accord et
l'armée est intéressée aussi par ce
genre de
gendarmerie
hélicoptères de la gendarmerie nationale
pour donner un autre exemple concret
eurofir 410 sera aussi à bord des Falcon
de la Marine nationale un mot quand même
sur les sites qui participent à ce
projet alors on sait que Safran est
quand même présent sur le territoire de
50 ans en Yvelines avec aircraft
quels sont les sites qui contribuent à
cette technologie là alors pour eurofir
410 c'est un système qui est conçu à
Massy développé par nos ingénieurs et
ensuite qui est produit dans nos usines
en France on fait participer nos usines
de Fougères Montluçon Dijon et Poitiers
et au-delà de nos usines safran s'appuie
sur un tissu industriel de PME française
et européenne
je suppose oui tout à fait
un mot parce que tout le monde sait pas
exactement ce que ça prend c'est
dites-nous ce que ça prend c'est un
grand groupe aéronautique de 80 000
personnes à travers le monde avec 120
000 personnes
donc on a 12 filiales principales et
dans les domaines de l'aéronautique des
équipements aéronautiques des intérieurs
d'avions et également de la défense
monsieur fourgon c'est un honneur de la
part d'une entreprise c'est un honneur
de contribuer aux Jeux Olympiques on
sait votre motivation vous aussi à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de contribuer
à cette grand événement comment ça se
passe justement avec les entreprises
aujourd'hui par rapport aux Jeux
Olympiques d'abord ce sont des
entreprises comme d'une certaine
souveraineté dont on parle
qui sont très intégrés d'ailleurs à
toute dispositif sur de depuis le départ
de des JO en tout cas bon nous on a
17000 entreprises vous savez on est un
des gros PIB
donc PIB par habitant et avec un très
fort secteur défense bien sûr avec des
PME des gros et des plus petits et bien
entendu c'est extrêmement stabilisant
d'avoir des gens qui travaillent sur des
gros marchés qui passent d'ailleurs
souvent entre les gouttes des crises on
a quand même des moments difficiles et
bon donc c'est très structurant bon
d'être on est très belle boîte c'est
aussi bien oui
les secteurs assez et mais surtout en
plus il y a des formations parce que ces
entreprises sont consommateurs de
formation de haute valeur ajoutée ce qui
sont sur des secteurs quand même très
stratégiques de niveau
et bien sûr il y a des très belles
écoles d'ingénieurs ici vous savez
jusqu'à
donc voilà donc c'est un vivier qui se
passe bien qui est quand même rentre en
contact et et où il y a beaucoup de
synergie donc bien entendu on les aime
bien justement ce genre de clients
c'est bien la preuve que les JO c'est
évidemment un
challenge sportif mais au-delà c'est
aussi un enjeu économique et un enjeu
d'entreprise alors bien sûr c'est
toujours le le royaume on se dit
toujours
là je vous rappelle que pour les cibles
en sécurité donc on est bien que je
crois qu'il y a eu 200 millions
d'attaques cybers sur les JO de Londres
et 4 milliards sont les sur les sur
Tokyo donc bien sûr grosse préoccupation
qu'on a sur
Paris et l'année dessus justement cette
entreprise sont extrêmement mobilisées
pour prévenir bien entendu des attaques
cybers donc voilà écoutez en tout cas il
y a une synergie formidable entre des
événements de cette taille là entre les
PME les grands groupes bien sûr comme
safran et d'autres donc bien sûr nous
vous savez ça va nous sommes heureux
sur safran par rapport à la
cybersécurité est-ce que c'est quand
vous développez un produit aujourd'hui
chez Safran vous pensez à intégrer aussi
de la cybersécurité ça va l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est un des enjeux forts aujourd'hui
avec le développement des attaques donc
nous intégrons tout à fait
ceci dans nos dans nos produits
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Caroline
Lemine et merci beaucoup Jean-Michel
faugus yo on aura d'autres occasions de
parler justement de cette coopération
avec avec des entreprises
en vue de ces Jeux olympiques de 2024 et
puisque je rappelle quand même que les
Yvelines ont des sites très importants
pour pour l'organisation de ces Jeux
Olympiques merci activité économique et
attractivité sportive
[Musique]
et j'en profite pour rappeler que notre
site de Massy est à la recherche
toujours de nouveaux talents pour nous
aider à développer nos nouvelles
technologies
parce que nous utilisons de la mécanique
de l'optique de l'électronique de
l'électrique c'est très vaste des
ingénieurs des mines ça vous
intéresserait tout à fait justement il y
a un site de sourire à Versailles un
nouveau site pour pour cette fameuse
école qui est l'école des Mines qui
donnent des grandes grandes écoles
françaises qui viennent s'ouvrir sur à
Versailles même Gabriel Gontier
jeudi dernier avait lieu la pose
symbolique de la toute première pierre
du futur campus alors le but de cette
pause elle est symbolique je l'ai dit
mais c'était surtout d'officialiser la
construction du site sur le plateau de
Versailles satori pierre Bédié président
du conseil départemental des Yvelines
nous explique les enjeux du projet au
niveau du département mais vous le
verrez aussi au niveau national les
Yvelines c'est aujourd'hui un territoire
où la recherche est développement ce qui
fait la richesse d'un pays c'est dans
les Yvelines que il y a le plus de
pépites et ce laboratoire c'est
laboratoire c'est trois laboratoires des
mines vont venir nourrir ses pépites et
c'est pourquoi le département a fait cet
effort très très important il y a ici
dans les Yvelines un écosystème de
recherche et développement au service
d'une industrie extrêmement performante
qui est l'avenir de la France
Gabriel peut-être quand même un mot de
cette école des mines je disais elle
était créée sous Louis XVI
c'est une des grandes grandes écoles
françaises en grande grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs françaises exactement vous
l'avez dit au début de cette émission il
s'agit historiquement de la première
école des mines françaises alors elle a
été créée en 1783 sous Louis XVI vous
l'avez dit à l'origine le but était de
former des directeurs intelligents pour
les mines du royaume de France
aujourd'hui c'est l'une des plus
anciennes et des plus sélectives et
prestigieuses école d'ingénieurs
français alors justement l'implantation
du campus témoigne de la volonté du
département de rendre les Yvelines
encore plus innovantes et encore plus
attractive tout ça en regroupant sur le
territoire des établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs et des
laboratoires de recherche c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous explique Vincent
la flèche le directeur général de
l'École des Mines de Paris PSL qui nous
parle des trois laboratoires qui verront
le jour nous avons trois laboratoires
qui se regroupent dans des domaines qui
touchent la transition énergétique et
les matériaux pour la transition
énergétique et également tout ce qui est
robotique véhicule autonome nous sommes
effectivement au cœur de la transition
énergétique et de la transition
environnementale
300 chercheurs quand même qui vont être
formés sur ce site
pour le financement je crois que c'est
le département qui a beaucoup investi
pour le financement de ce campus
exactement l'investissement du
département s'élève à 98 millions
d'euros je profite j'en profite pour
ajouter que le but de cette école c'est
de former des ingénieurs qui viendront
compléter les équipes des 250 chercheurs
qui sont déjà présents sur place
et on a une date de d'ouverture alors la
date elle reste à fixer ça dépend de
plein de choses mais le campus devrait
voir le jour en septembre 2024
l'objectif c'est la rentrée bien sûr
merci beaucoup Gabriel Montier et bien
il est temps pour nous d'ouvrir une
grande page sport
[Musique]
je sais pas pourquoi je crie comme ça
mais parce que peut-être parce que vous
êtes là Michael vidéo
et vous avez un invité et si je peux
dire ça va pas n'importe qui exactement
un champion du monde sur piste master
avec nous pour parler sport justement
je suppose que puisque
il est là qu'on va parler de cyclisme
exactement on va tout de suite prendre
justement la direction du Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on
va revenir sur les performances des
Français lors des championnats du monde
de parasyclisme les Tricolores emporté
combien de médailles à votre avis on
nous l'a dit tout à l'heure 17 médailles
exactement
[Musique]
de compétition des images de Patrick
Jacques de diction la France a briller
lors de ces Mondiaux de parasyclisme sur
piste 2022 à domicile dans ce blodon
national de 50 ans en Yvelines et
tricolore emporté 17 médailles pendant
les quatre jours de compétition les
Bleus terminent 3e au tableau des
médailles en termes de performance
sportive les athlètes ont bien répondu
présent et on a de nombreuses médailles
après la deuxième satisfaction c'est
qu'il y avait trois quatre jeunes
dont on attendait pas ce parcours sur
ces championnats et qui ont prouvé que
2028 c'était pour eux un peu trop loin
et qu'il voulait avancer un peu plus
vite que prévu côté bleu la star de ces
championnats du monde restera Alexandre
leotté ce jeune français de 22 ans
termine ses mondiaux avec un bilan de 4
médailles d'or une médaille d'argent et
des records du monde ce dimanche le
pista remporte notamment l’omnium et le
15 km scratch j'avais beaucoup bossé
j'ai amélioré beaucoup de choses dans
mon quotidien aussi pour que ça
fonctionne le mieux possible et je vois
que ça fonctionne et que le fait de
souffrir à l'entraînement ça paye donc
je suis très content une sportive local
c'est également distingué Christelle
Ribaut termine 3e du scratch 10 km en
catégorie C2 j'ai vraiment heureuse
vraiment comme je disais c'est une
médaille de bronze mais qui vaut de l'or
par rapport à tous mes efforts consentis
depuis quelques années c'est une belle
récompense surtout chez moi à la maison
devant devant ma famille mes proches mes
amis et sur le lieu dont où je où je
coache aussi toute la semaine parce que
je travaille aussi ici au tout ce beau
monde se retrouvera dans moins de deux
ans à l'occasion des Jeux paralympiques
de Paris l'événement se déroulera du 28
août au 8 septembre 2024
on va débriefer ajustement avec vous il
y a une Jarrier c'est Championnat du
Monde comment ça s'est passé pour pour
cette équipe de France plutôt bien 17
médailles un bon bilan
on peut pas on peut difficilement faire
mieux je pense que en effet 17 médailles
là c'est c'est quand même énorme moi
j'ai surtout souvenir d'avoir participé
au championnat du monde de parasite de
paracétisme en 2018 et je crois qu'on
était 6 ou 7 athlète seulement à s'être
déplacé moi j'étais pilote de Raphaël
avec l'équipe de France moi j'étais
pilote de Raphaël Baugé qui a fait
médaille de bronze
tandem
à l'époque et c'est vrai qu'on était
désolé
on était ouais 6 7 6 6 7 à tête grand
maximum c'était vraiment pas énorme et
aujourd'hui on voit que les moyens qui
ont été mis en place pour Paris 2024
aussi bien sur para cyclisme que sur
d'autres sports en règle générale et
bien porte leur porte leurs fruits c'est
vrai que la moisson qui était déjà très
florissante à Tokyo pour le pour le
paracyclisme bah fait que ça continue la
la synergie est positive c'est vrai que
c'est quand même formidable de sortir
2021 avec autant de autant et c'est plus
facile de sortir avec une belle moisson
que que quand c'est difficile donc là
ben voilà c'est je pense une continuité
il y a pas de surprise mais c'est plutôt
une continuité il y a quelques athlètes
qu'on attendait pas mais surtout des
nouveaux noms et ça c'est c'est bien
parce que je me souviens aussi que à
l'époque la discussion elle veut des tn
de l'époque qui n'est plus le DTN
aujourd'hui mais elle a des thèmes de
l'époque c'était justement la détection
de d'un nouveau talent qui était
compliqué exactement est-ce que il y a
aussi un effort de la part je sais pas
des handicapés à se mettre des sports
peut-être plus plus facilement qui est
quelques années ou pas je pense que
c'est ils avaient déjà la volonté mais
il y avait pas les structures peut-être
manque de structure manque de
communication je sais que justement des
thèmes en parler
mais il y avait très peu de
communication parce que le gros problème
c'est que il y a une de ce qui me disait
il y avait un ministère pour pour les
handicapés et qui était différent du
ministère de sportif et donc du coup il
y avait pas de colliers voilà et donc je
vais pas dire quelque chose se met en
place maintenant ce n'est pas vrai juste
aujourd'hui du fait des pas des JO Paris
2024 il y a des moyens et il y a plus de
moyens et donc du coup un accompagnement
pour les athlètes qui est qui est
facilité
la star on va dire de ces championnats
du monde 22 ans il termine avec un bilan
de 4 médailles d'or une médaille
d'argent pareil vous pouvez pas faire
mieux bah si il pouvait faire à la place
bien sûr je pense que ce sont des
championnats qui sont amplement réussi
mais c'est pareil c'est pas une surprise
c'est une confirmation parce qu'il avait
déjà fait des titres à Tokyo l'année
dernière donc c'est pas euh
on savait qu'il était là il répond
présent il a changé il nous explique il
a changé des choses dans son
entraînement dans sa façon d'appréhender
les appréhender les événements et puis
tout simplement il grandit il mûrit donc
ben je pense que pour lui la suite
devrait encore être meilleur sauf si
dans un autre pays on découvre aussi une
autre pépite c'est aussi la
particularité de du sport olympique
c'est que d'un seul coup vous pouvez
avoir un gars qui sort de nulle part et
qui qui viennent et qui fait des des
supers résultats et c'est ce qui s'est
un petit peu passé avec Alexandre en
2000 en 2020
quand même quand vous avez 22 ans je
pense que là oui en effet il est et puis
on pratique jusqu'à quel âge le cyclisme
44 ans 44 ans
et c'est une athlète que je connaissais
quand elle était valide
moi j'ai 45 ans oui j'ai 46 dans
quelques dans quelques heures
[Rires]
Ribot oui 44 ans qui fait nuit de faire
des exploits et la particularité de
Christelle c'est que elle est dans une
catégorie où elle se bagarre enfin elle
compte enfin elle concourt plutôt parce
qu'on n'est pas dans la bagarre elle
participe à des épreuves où il y a des
athlètes qui ont leurs deux jambes alors
que elle ne qu'avec une seule
jambe
je voulais vous poser c'est à dire que
les différences de handicap ça joue
quand même beaucoup non c'est ah non
tout est catégorisé tout est catégorisé
et en fait ils ont un quand on arrive
sur une compétition nationale ou
internationale vous avez un bilan à
faire devant un médecin un médecin du
sport qui va vous mettre dans une
catégorie dans une autre donc en effet
vous avez les moins handicapés donc les
handicaps invisibles comme Marie
patouiller peut l'être ou encore que
qui est la versaillesse et qui a
remporté deux argent
donc Marie patouillé elle elle a une
malformation au niveau du pied donc
quand on la voit au quotidien on le voit
pas tout à fait
et donc elle elle est en catégorie C5 et
ensuite plus vous avez un chiffre qui se
rapproche de 0 au nombre de C1 et ben
plus vous êtes handicapé et là et là
quand on voit
quand on est sportif quand on a une
carrière valide et que l'on voit
certains chronos dans des catégories C2
ou C1 ce sont des vrais leçons de vie
encore plus admiratif exactement moi je
me souviens d'un russe je me souviens
d'un rus on était en même hôtel qui ne
pouvait pas manger tout seul et quand il
était sur le vélo bah il faisait des
chronos que je n'avais jamais été
capable de réaliser sur le premier
départ c'était d'ailleurs qu'il n'avait
pas de membre supérieur sur le départ
sur le premier tour c'était vraiment
difficile mais une fois que la machine
était envoyée oh là là c'était
impressionnant à voir et puis après vous
avez d'autres d'autres je me souviens
d'un Espagnol un bras en moins une jambe
en moins et vous dites le mec il est sur
un vélo et il prend du plaisir et il
s'amuse et ils ont toujours le sourire
et ça rigole et et ça rigole et ça et ça
va même entre
des supers moments et moi c'est j'ai
fait une saison avec avec Raphaël
bougilais et j'en garde une un très très
bon
souvenirs
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure il a
fini deux fois à 4e et il était
forcément un petit peu déçu de ces
championnats du monde je suis déçu déçu
pour nous pour les personnes qui nous
accompagnent
et
[Musique]
c'était surtout après le kilomètres
honnêtement j'ai pris une grosse claque
dans la figure on fait le deuxième temps
des qualifications mais
je me doutais un peu que les Anglais ils
avaient géré leur dernière partie de
kilomètres et bah ça c'est vu après
ça vous fait quoi il y a une juridier de
le voir thermique deux fois 4e ou qui
connaissez si bien quatrième
il a fait une médaille de bronze à Tokyo
l'année dernière et il a un très bon
pilote
quand un Caleyron il a un très bon
pilote voilà c'est une collaboration qui
est en train de se mettre en place
valide
qui était en équipe de France encore
l'année dernière où il y a deux ans
voilà qui a décidé de de passer sur le
sport par olympique un super un super
gars Quentin vraiment quelqu'un de très
très sympa voilà c'est une collaboration
qui est en train de se mettre en place
il faut un peu de temps moi je me
souviens que on avait gagné beaucoup de
beaucoup de temps sur les sur les
premières semaines et puis dès qu'on
arrivait à enchaîner des jours de
roulage on progressé énormément mais là
voilà eux ils sont déjà un très haut
niveau et donc pour aller grappiller les
derniers les derniers
c'est c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus dur
un petit peu à l'image de l'équipe de
France valide je pense que c'est bien
qu'ils aient fait cette quatrième place
maintenant ils auront ils auront une
période
complètement voilà donc c'est bien de
prendre une claque maintenant ça permet
très ça permet de se remettre en
question de de savoir parce que le
projet avec avec Quentin est encore pour
pour 2 ans il y a pas de problème
là-dessus donc c'est pas une mauvaise
chose j'ai pas appelé Raphaël parce que
c'était trop tôt pour pour pouvoir
débrief avec lui je l'appellerai la
semaine prochaine pour avoir des pour
avoir des débris de leur sentiment bien
sûr je sais qu'ils ont toujours besoin
de souffler mais
au point de vue public
environ 2000 personnes sur les quatre
jours de compétition c'est pas si ma
c'est plus que prévu initialement on va
justement écouter le public de ce vélo
de national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
puis en handisport moi-même et moi je
fais pas de piste mais du coup j'avais
mon club qui te représenté par la France
donc je viens encourager les copains
de vélo notamment pour la première fois
que je viens à 50 ans en Yvelines et je
l'ai appris quand je suis venu au
championnat du monde élite c'est comme
ça que j'ai appris et puis ils vont
comme je connaissais pas trop le sport
paralympique comme on dit donc ça m'a
permis de conduire et puis c'est sympa
c'est bien on est venu la semaine
dernière ou celle d'avant pour les
classiques et ça nous a vachement plus
parce que c'était c'est assez abordable
parce que c'est des petites épreuves qui
sont assez cool parce que nous on est
sur du cycliste sur route normalement et
quand on a vu qu'il y avait deux
nouveaux révélote et en plus le Para
cyclisme on est venu et puis parce que
on adore Marie patouiller aussi
demi-spectateurs il y a une Jarrier et
ben génial parce que en effet à Rio
c'était pas le cas c'est pas du tout
ben c'est bien parce que ce sont des
athlètes à part entière c'est pas juste
des gens qui montent sur un vélo pour un
championnat du monde c'est quand même
des des coups des sportifs qui
s'entraînent tout au long de l'année
avec des vraies belles structures des
entraîneurs et donc c'est quand même
vachement plus sympa de moi j'ai eu la
chance moi j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
faire de des belles épreuves sur le vélo
de Rome avec du monde dans les tribunes
ben ça vous y croyez quoi tout
simplement merci
avec plaisir toutes ces précisions sur
les Mondiaux valides et également sur
sur ces championnats du monde qui sont
déroulés la semaine dernière
j'encourage tout le monde à venir voir
parce que parce que ce sont des leçons
de vie comme on l'a comme on l'a dit
tout d'abord c'est très spectaculaire
oui ça reste ah bah oui et en plus c'est
voilà parce que il a de voir c'est des
gens qui sont venus voir les valides se
dit tiens je vais venir voir les les
paralympiques et donc du coup ils
peuvent comparer et finalement on
s'aperçoit que il y a certaines
performances qui sont qui sont des
belles performances merci beaucoup vous
en prie on va passer au handball avec la
victoire de plaisir les clés en National
3 c'est ça exactement jouer ce weekend
dans le championnat de National 3
plaisirs les clés c'est imposé assez
facilement ce weekend face à
Bois-Colombes un résultat qui permet aux
Yvelines d'être dans la première partie
du classement des images de Grégory
canae un match pour se placer dans la
première partie du classement plaisir
les clés recevez Bois-Colombes les
derniers du classement à l'occasion de
la 5e journée de Nationale 3 après un
début de match accroché aussi bien au
niveau du score que de l'engagement les
Yvelinois arrivent à creuser des carres
le score à la pause 14 à 10 pour les
plaisirs rois les cinq premières minutes
ont été un peu un peu dur pour nous on
le temps qu'on rentre dans le match le
temps qu'on s'adapte à leur défense et
puis après on a réagi en changeant de
système défensif et c'est là qu'on a
commencé à reprendre le dessus donc je
suis super satisfait de la manière dont
on a réagi sur le terrain à partir voilà
à 7/8 je crois c'est là où on commence à
reprendre le dessus donc faut que ça
continue dans cet état d'esprit là et
c'est parfait pour cette première
mi-temps au retour des vestiaires le
club de plaisir les clés continuent à
scorer pour gérer son avance malgré un
petit passage à vide bois-colombe ne
reviendra pas dans le match score final
31 à 26 on a pris les trois points donc
c'est c'est important après moi je suis
perfectionniste donc je vais retenir les
10 minutes où on a pris l'eau on est à
plus 10 et on n'a pas le droit de
laisser espérer l'adversaire de le faire
de lui faire croire qui peut revenir au
score on doit tuer ce match on doit être
à plus 10 + 15 et voilà moi je vais
retenir ça et après je suis satisfait
des gars je suis content il y a encore
du travail avec cette victoire le club
yvelinway 6e du championnat de N3 lors
de son prochain match plaisir des clés à
fontra cette fois-ci le leader du
classement le Paris Sport Club la
rencontre est programmée ce samedi 5
novembre à 20h toujours à domicile
alors ça c'était une belle victoire mais
la prochaine fois ça risque d'être un
peu plus compliqué non oui il fasse au
leader un vaincu Paris donc forcément ça
sera beaucoup plus compliqué mais on y
croit du côté de plaisir les clés il
faut toujours y croire absolument il y a
pas de raison il faut une bon début de
saison là c'était la dernière équipe ça
sera la meilleure équipe du championnat
dans quelques jours
dans le championnat deux fédéral 2 un
très beau week-end pour nos imminois on
va commencer par plaisir qui a réussi à
s'imposer 31 à 14 sur le terrain de
Boulogne-Billancourt de son côté
Versailles s'impose 20 à 13 sur le
terrain d'Antony au classement les plus
Irois sont deuxième de la poule avec 25
points de leur côté les versaillers
remontent à la huitième place la
prochaine journée programmée le 6
novembre plaisir recevra Courbevoie et
Versailles Boulogne-Billancourt
et le foot avec Poissy qui continue ça
très belle saison exactement en football
on arrête pu laisse Poissy les pissé se
sont imposées deux buza 1 face à Saint
privé Saint-Hilaire ce weekend un bon
résultat face à un mal classique qui
permet aux Illinois d'être deuxième du
classement de cette Pula de National 2
l'équipe est seulement à deux petits
points du Racing qui a quand même un
match en plus donc il peut être premier
pas mal et on continue avec un chiffre
qui fait beaucoup parler c'est le c'est
ce que gagne Mbappé exactement les
détails du nouveau contrat de Killian
Mbappe au PG ont été révélés par nos
confrères du Parisien le joueur parisien
serait l'un des sportifs les mieux payés
de la planète dans le détail il a un
salaire de combien votre avis Gabriel
alors j'ai pu le chiffre en tête mais je
crois que c'est impressionnant
alors 72 millions d'euros brut par an
mais aussi une prime à la signature de
180 millions d'euros ainsi qu'une clause
de fidélité si je peux dire chaque année
en septembre qu'il y a par exemple a
reçu à montant évolutif il a 70 millions
d'euros en septembre il touchera 80 à
millions en septembre 2023 et 90
millions après l'été 2024 en tout le
joueur originaire de Bondy va toucher
630 millions brutes s'il reste encore 3
ans au PSG il est lié au PSG jusqu'en
2024 avec une année supplémentaire
vous demander pour 78 exactement j'ai
rendez-vous dans quelques jours après la
direction
tellement impressionnant qu'on sait pas
ce que ça veut dire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut acheter avec ça
qu'est-ce qu'on peut acheter et et
est-ce que est-ce qu'il a raison de
vouloir se barrer
deuxième question ça peut être le faire
rester oui effectivement on termine par
le golf du golf du coup pour faire se
rencontrer les entreprises ce vendredi
21 octobre 50 ans en Yvelines organisé
un Open de golf l'Open Sky TV 78
plusieurs membres des différentes
entreprises présentes sur le territoire
de l'agglomération se sont affrontés le
temps d'une journée et d'un parcours une
cinquantaine de chefs d'entreprise et te
rassemblées on écoute les réactions
micro de tv78 beaucoup de réponses des
partenaires beaucoup d'engagements un
fort une fort caractéristique du manisme
qui était là beaucoup d'entre elles
beaucoup de solidarité parce que le Golf
National de 59 vignes c'est un parcours
golfique de très haut niveau avec des
joueurs peut-être qui était un petit peu
moins donc il faut se battre contre le
parcours première fois pour moi l'albat
donc belle découverte et de jolis green
assez difficile et bien défendu donc un
vrai bonheur à jouer aujourd'hui on
était avec un autre ou une autre partie
de personnes qui ont été aussi qui
jouaient qu'on connaissait pas et en
effet c'était très convivial très
sympathique et on a pu jouer sur le
parcours qui est bien entretenu sur
place Patrice
parce que le matin il pleuvait et puis
après ça s'est levé non et c'était très
convivial et c'est très intéressant pour
les chefs d'entreprise voilà d'en voir
un moment de de détente dans laquelle
ils peuvent discuter voilà de golf
pendant le parcours et d'affaires après
est-ce que vous avez bien joué aussi
terminée c'est ça c'est terminé je
reviens la semaine prochaine du coup
avec plaisir et on va demander à Mbappé
un peu d'argent
[Musique]
alors je vous propose de découvrir
l'oeuvre d'un jeune peintre qui
s'appelle Arnaud Adami et qui explose à
l'espace Richou à Versailles jusqu'au 20
novembre prochain
on s'interroge souvent sur ce que c'est
l'art contemporain certains peut-être
visiter je sais pas ce week-end Paris
plus par Basel ou Asian now à Paris il y
a plusieurs formes de Dark contemporain
et fut même un temps où on s'est
interrogé sur la pertinence de la
peinture ce qu'il fallait pas trouver
d'autres supports pour pour faire de la
contemporain bien si on s'interroge là
dessus il faut aller voir les œuvres
d'Arnaud Adami qui vont fournir une
réponse parce que leur contemporain ça
consiste simplement à rendre compte de
la société telle qu'elle est avec avec
des peintures assez très intéressant
alors il peint c'est pas des livreurs de
délivrero des des gens qui ramassaient
des des éboueurs qui ramassent les
poubelles des instruments voilà comme
comment on les voit ici
monsieur
des choses de la vie de tous les jours
et je trouve que c'est absolument
formidable ce qui fait parce que il y a
des voilà des gens qui se sont
invisibles dans la vie dans la vie
quotidienne et grâce à grâce à ses
peintures ces voitures hyper réaliste
on redécouvre autrement tous ces métiers
d'abord il y a des couleurs absolument
formidables et je trouve que c'est un
travail artistique absolument
passionnant alors je sais que vous
pouvez retrouver Arnaud Adami dans le V
YP que nous avons consacré qui est
présenté par Véronique lecabut et sinon
je rappelle que c'est à l'espace Richou
à Versailles jusqu'au 20 novembre
prochain et on termine par un côté sur
la météo vous voulez savoir le temps
qu'il fait demain
on le répète ça fait du bien j'étais pas
en plateau tout à l'heure le matin
matin c'est un poil frisquet on va dire
c'est pas c'est pas totalement
ensoleillé il y a quelques nuages mais
peu à peu regardez le mesure que le jour
avance on passe l'après-midi et là c'est
le beau temps presque partout dans les
Yvelines avec des températures entre 18
19 degrés 20 degrés presque ça va c'est
plutôt correct mais pour les vacances
c'est bien aussi pour les enfants par
exemple mais comme on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est peut-être un peu chaud
pour la pour la saison merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Gabriel merci beaucoup
Miguel et à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro à demain probablement du 7 8
[Musique]